how carefully coordinated rendezvous in
Ukraine's rebel-controlled region the
freed prisoners include Ukrainian riot
police accused of firing on protesters
in 2014 the controversial swap has
angered some activists there but others
see it as a crucial step to improving
ties with Moscow it's the second major
prisoner exchange this year September
saw another swap that brought inmates
home and fostered hope that the war in
eastern Ukraine could soon be over an
early victory for Ukraine's new
president Vladimir's Olinsky normally we
have agreed the first step to unblock
the war is returning out soldiers
political prisoners for more than five
years the Ukrainian army has been
fighting Russian backed separatists in
the country's East the war has cost
around fourteen thousand lives and
turned a key industrial region into a
conflict zone efforts to stop the
fighting have so far come to little when
szalinski was elected in April he
promised to restart the peace process
that culminated in a meeting this month
with his French German and Russian
counterparts in which Sunday's exchange
was agreed an exchange between both
sides in this conflict based on swapping
everyone the deal is again raising hopes
for swift resolution to the conflict but
major hurdles between Russia and Ukraine
still need to be overcome before peace
is possible joining us now from Moscow
is correspondent eben escovitch who is
following today's events a forest good
to see you even do you know yet how many
prisoners have been exchanged and who
they might be well by the end of the day
we expect that the exchange will total
between 100 and 200 total prisoners so
far of the two breakaway Republic's that
have handled the exchange only one has
gone so far
that is Lugansk and we expect any ask a
bit later today Lugansk sent 25
prisoners back to Kiev and Keef sent 63
to Lugansk most of these prisoners were
from the Lugansk odd where central
government soldiers fighting for Kiev
and the reverse side actually has a bit
plenty of people who have nothing to do
with the war these were included that's
why the Ukrainian side is sending so
much more to the breakaway republic to
get their soldiers back some of these as
was mentioned at the top of the
broadcast are these five Berkut police
officers who fired on urine Maidan
protesters they have nothing to do with
the war and they have actually sparked
some protests in Kiev last night
activists stood outside of the prison
where they were held hoping to block
their passage they weren't we expect
them to be sent over to done yet later
today they are waiting at the checkpoint
and how significant is this prisoner
exchange looking at if it's to ease
tensions between Russia and Ukraine it's
quite significant in the fact that these
prisoner exchanges have gotten the
leaders back to the table the first
prisoner exchange this year in September
was it was the first time the peace
process had gotten going since 2016 so
it had been stalled for three years and
the second one to end of the year is the
second largest prisoner swap over these
six years it was a key part of the
Normandy summit agreement earlier this
month and we expect that peace talks
will be able to continue now at some
point in 2020 early reports suggest
early April for the actual important
points as was mentioned that the
ceasefire has not actually been
implemented but the prisoner swap is
what is going to get us to that point
even what do people in Russia make off
the peace efforts between the two
countries Russia and Ukraine
well Moscow from all indications Moscow
wants peace there this they're seeing
this as a moment especially especially
because the lansky has so clearly said
he wants to end the war as a time to
negotiate the major issue is the fact
that Moscow feels like it holds all the
car
and it's not really going to let go of
its leverage keeve keeve of course it
wants better terms for itself in Moscow
is going to hold firm and so foreign
policy analysts that are speaking in
Moscow were following on Twitter today a
lot of them are saying well you know
this prisoners swap is all well and good
but what we can expect in 2020 is a
frozen conflict not an actual end to the
war so this is hopeful for the new year
but we'll have to see in the new year
what will happen what actually happens
with the war even Gersh povitch in
moscow thank you